Salut tout le monde,
je suis Léo de DirtyBiology
et je suis ici avec Mister Geopolitix
et Théo, de Balade Mentale,
et on est dans l'archipel norvégien
du Svalbard, à 1300 km du pôle Nord.
- Et on est ici pour vous faire découvrir
ce petit bout de territoire
qui sert de laboratoire
aux scientifiques du monde entier
pour étudier
le dérèglement climatique.
L'archipel du Svalbard
a été découvert en 1596
par l'explorateur néerlandais
Willem Barentsz.
Entre le 17ème siècle et le 18ème,
il a servi de camp de base international
pour la chasse à la baleine
et le commerce de peaux.
Ce n'est qu'au début du 20ème siècle
que John Munro Longyear,
homme d'affaires américain,
décide d'exploiter les sols
et les montagnes de l'archipel
qui sont très riches en charbon.
- En 1906, il crée la première société
des mines de l'Arctique
et il passe 10 ans à investir
pour développer cette petite ville
qui servira de camp de base
pour l'exploitation du charbon,
qui porte d'ailleurs son nom :
Longyearbyen.
- Là, on va monter
dans une mine désaffectée,
pour tenter d'explorer un peu ce qu'il y a.
- Donc là, elles sont fermées,
elles sont condamnées,
on va essayer de voir quand même
si on peut y rentrer,
c'est un peu déconseillé d'y aller
parce qu'avec le temps,
il y a des risques d'éboulements
et des risques d'effondrement du bâtiment.
Donc on va être prudents
et on va voir ce qu'on trouve.
- Allez, c'est parti !
- Chaque année, environ 200 mineurs,
suédois et norvégiens principalement,
venaient travailler
dans les conditions extrêmes de l'île,
attirés par la promesse de bons salaires.
- Là, on vient de monter,
je ne sais pas...
200 mètres de dénivelé peut-être.
Ici, il y a 22 millions de tonnes
de charbon qui ont été extraites
de la couche carbonifère.
Toutes les installations, toutes les infrastructures
sont des infrastructures minières.
C'est juste un passé "houillé" en fait,
on est dans le Roubaix de l'Arctique.
- On est dans un décor qui est
pratiquement intemporel.
En fait, la mine a été fermée
dans les années 1980
et on pourrait très bien être au fin fond
du Kansas ou de l'Arkansas en 1830,
il y a quelque chose
d'un peu surréel, quoi.
Moi, là, je me verrais bien avec un colt,
un petit chapeau,
ne pas m'être lavé depuis quelques semaines
et avoir traversé un désert.
- Allez !
Souplesse !
Waaah !
- Là, on a des bancs,
il y a des sacs de charbon,
quelques trucs
qui ont été laissés en l'état.
Ça a pris cher aussi, parce qu'après
40 ans minimum d'inoccupation,
le temps fait son travail.
- Le sol n'est pas très stable,
donc s'il y en a un qui passe au travers...
Visiblement, ils entreposaient
pas mal de matériel ici,
plein de pièces métalliques de type "rouages"
pour faire de la maintenance, on suppose.
Et donc ça, je n'ai strictement
aucune idée de ce que c'est.
Du coup, on va peut-être
éviter de le toucher.
En tout cas, ça a commencé à faire
des belles réactions chimiques à la base
et puis en haut, c'est tout blanc.
Là, tu as des systèmes de poids...
- C'est une balance !
- C'est une balance, ouais ?
- Ouais, c'est sûr.
- Elle est complètement
prise dans la glace,
il y a des stalactites
sur la moitié de l'appareil.
- Il y a encore les touches de la calculatrice
qui sont fonctionnelles !
Non mais c'est incroyable,
vraiment incroyable.
- Oh, le tableau électrique !
Oh là là, ça continue, beaucoup !
Je ne pense pas
qu'on soit sur le sol en fait,
à mon avis,
on est sur une dalle qui est sur des poutres.
- Eh bien, je crois qu'on vient
de trouver l'entrée de la mine.
La mine 2B,
qui était opérationnelle de 1937 à 1968.
Et strictement interdit d'y entrer,
comme l'atteste cette belle tête de mort.
- Les galeries ne sont pas ventilées
et donc, il y a probablement des galeries
qui sont pleines de méthane
qui peut exploser
et il n'y a pas du tout d'oxygène
dans la plupart des galeries.
Donc, tu peux t'étouffer, enfin...
même t'endormir sans t'en rendre compte
et ça fait un très bon rappel
des conditions de travail des mineurs...
C'était un métier très dangereux,
c'est un métier très dangereux
parce que tu peux tomber
sur une poche de gaz et ça explose
et tout le monde meurt
dans la galerie quoi.
*Plancher qui craque*
- Il faut toujours faire gaffe
dans ce genre de situation
parce que ce n'est pas anodin de visiter
ce genre de lieux abandonnés.
*Plancher qui craque fortement*
- Ça doit être hyper dur de bosser en hiver,
dans des températures abominables,
rentrer sous terre, creuser le permafrost,
extraire le charbon, sortir... il fait nuit...
De toute façon,
il fait tout le temps nuit en hiver.
Au total, 125 mineurs sont morts
dans les mines entre 1916 et 2016.
Aujourd'hui,
la plupart des mines ont fermé
à cause de la chute du prix du charbon
à la fin des années 2000
et celle qui est encore en activité,
sert principalement à alimenter
la ville de Longyearbyen en chauffage.
L'économie locale se tourne désormais
vers le tourisme, l'éducation et la recherche.
Pour vous montrer à quoi ressemble
une région polaire,
on est partis explorer
l'île de Spitsbergen.
L'archipel du Svalbard fait environ
61 000 km carrés.
La température annuelle moyenne
est de -5,6°C
et le thermomètre peut même
descendre jusqu'à -20°C.
Des conditions climatiques
très hostiles
qui font qu’il n’y a que très peu
d’espèces animales dans la région,
la plus emblématique
d'entre elles étant,
évidemment, l’ours polaire.
Même si leur nombre
est très difficile à recenser,
il y aurait entre 1900 et
3400 individus au Svalbard.
- L’ours, c’est un animal
qui est très curieux,
donc il faut qu’on se protège.
C’est un très grand prédateur.
Dès qu’on sort de la ville,
la police ne peut plus
assurer notre protection
et donc, il faut absolument
qu’on s’équipe d’un fusil
et d’un “flare gun”.
Je vais vous expliquer
un peu le principe, pourquoi je les porte.
- Même si elles sont très rares,
il y a eu 5 attaques mortelles
d’ours polaires durant ces
40 dernières années
et les autorités
sont extrêmement vigilantes
vis-à-vis des règles de sécurité
concernant l’animal.
Donc si on voit un ours au loin,
la première chose à faire,
c’est de les effrayer,
souvent, ça suffit.
Siffler, faire du bruit
et s'enfuir, surtout.
Si l’ours nous a repérés et
qu’il est un peu trop intéressé,
on se servira du “flare gun”
pour tirer soit des cartouches
de détresse rouges,
uniquement pour effrayer l’ours,
soit carrément des “flashs bang”
qui font une grosse explosion
lumineuse et sonore
et souvent, ça suffit
pour effrayer l’ours.
- Et est-ce que tu sais, en moyenne,
combien il y a d’ours
qui se font tuer comme ça
pour des sorties
de personnes hors de la ville ?
- Malheureusement,
il y a entre un et deux
ours qui sont tués par an
uniquement pour
la protection des hommes.
Il faut bien savoir que
personne n’a envie de tuer l’ours.
Malheureusement, ici, on habite
sur un de ses territoires.
Il y a souvent de la banquise
qui se forme dans les fjords
donc les phoques
viennent s’y reproduire
et les ours viennent
manger les phoques
donc, il est assez courant
de croiser des ours ici.
De toute façon,
les gens ici en ont suffisamment peur
pour éviter l’ours au maximum.
Et moi, je ne croise personne
en dehors de la ville
qui n’a pas un fusil.
Voilà, le fusil est à demi-chargé,
on va pouvoir y aller.
- On vient de trouver
un cadavre de renne,
très, très, très dispersé.
- Les rennes, ici, ils n’ont pas de prédateur.
Ils ont du mal à trouver
de la nourriture l’hiver.
Quand ils deviennent trop vieux,
à force de chercher l’herbe
au milieu des rochers,
parce que l’herbe affleure à peine,
ils usent leurs dents qui ne repoussent pas
comme les rongeurs.
Du coup, ils finissent par ne plus
arriver à se nourrir
quand ils sont trop vieux et ils meurent.
Et donc là, ils vont se faire
probablement manger
par les renards polaires.
Donc ça, il ne faut pas toucher,
il y a des virus qui se baladent
et des trucs qu’on n'a
pas trop envie d’avoir, notamment la rage.
Bon là, ça va commencer à être
un peu raide jusqu’au plateau.
Là, c’est le printemps,
tu entends les oiseaux.
Nous, en hiver,
on n'entendait rien du tout.
Il y avait : lagopèdes, rennes,
renards et ours.
Il n'y a rien d’autre.
- Ouais, il n'y a que dalle en fait.
- C’est assez simple
de reconnaître les traces
parce qu’il n’y a que
quatre animaux dans le coin.
- C’est désert en fait,
on est dans un désert.
- Alors que les eaux sont hyper riches,
le territoire est complètement vide.
- Ouais.
Tu comprends que finalement
l’ours soit considéré,
comme un mammifère marin
parce que lui,
il ne bouffe que ce qu’il y a dans la mer.
Il a raison, c’est là où
il y a la richesse et l’énergie.
- C’est une stèle en mémoire de celle
qui s’est fait manger par un ours ici.
Ça fait partie des rares accidents
de ces 20 dernières années.
Elles étaient deux femmes
qui étaient montées sur le plateau
et elles n’avaient aucun fusil,
aucun “flare gun”,
donc ça, c’est la triste conséquence
de quand on ne s’équipe pas
comme il faut.
Ça passe, ça passe
et un jour, ça casse.
Voilà.
Là, les gars, je crois que le ressenti
est aux alentours de -20°C.
- Ouais, il y a moyen.
- On est impressionné de voir
que ça peut être aussi hostile.
Encore là, on a de la chance, on est à une période
où ce n’est pas le plus froid
mais en deux minutes, on peut avoir les doigts
complètement frigorifiés.
Ce qui peut arriver quand
on ne fait pas gaffe, physiquement,
c’est les engelures,
donc les bouts des doigts, les bouts des pieds.
On fait des checks régulièrement,
il faut les bouger très régulièrement.
Si la situation dégénère,
ce genre d’engelures,
ce n’est pas quelque chose
qui va se résorber en quelques mois.
Il y a vraiment un risque que ce soit à vie
et que ça mène même parfois
à des amputations.
On essaie souvent de comparer
avec un désert de sable
ou de la jungle pour savoir
si c’est un milieu
dans lequel on pourrait survivre
juste quelques semaines,
voire quelques jours
et c'est vrai qu'ici,
il n’y a rien qui pousse,
il n’y a pas d’alimentation,
il n’y a pas d’abri…
On ne tiendrait vraiment,
vraiment pas longtemps.
- Depuis les années 1970,
la température en Arctique
a augmenté de 2°C
alors qu’elle a augmenté de 0,6°C
dans le reste du monde.
La communauté scientifique
a donc les yeux rivés sur l’archipel
car il sert de laboratoire
pour mieux comprendre
les changements
climatiques mondiaux.
Greenpeace vient de lancer
une expédition
qui part de l’Arctique
pour aller en Antarctique
pour préserver
la biodiversité des océans
et sensibiliser au sujet
du changement climatique.
On va sur l’Esperanza,
qui est un des bateaux
de Greenpeace.
- Pouvez-vous nous dire
tout ce que vous savez
à propos du phénomène
de fonte des glaces sur les océans
et du réchauffement climatique ?
- Le changement climatique
est plus rapide dans cette région
qu'ailleurs dans le monde.
Lorsque la banquise fond,
elle part de la neige des glaciers
vers les océans,
ce qui renforce le changement climatique
parce que moins de lumière
du soleil est réfléchie.":0,"displayProperty":"Text"}
Normalement, les glaciers réfléchissent
les radiations solaires qui arrivent
et les renvoient,
alors que les océans
absorbent plus de cette chaleur
et se réchauffent donc de plus en plus.
- Selon un rapport de l’Agence
environnementale norvégienne
qui a été publié en 2019,
les températures à Svalbard
pourraient augmenter
de 7 à 10 degrés d'ici 2100.
- L’écosystème ici, en Arctique,
est basé sur les banquises.
Tout dépend au moins directement,
parfois indirectement, des banquises.
La base de la chaîne alimentaire ici,
est une algue
qui pousse et vit sous la glace en hiver.
Entre le Svalbard et le Groenland,
se trouve le détroit de Fram,
où il y a des banquises toute l'année.
L’océan Atlantique se dirige vers le nord
à travers le détroit de Fram
et les eaux polaires de l’océan Arctique
vers le sud,
donc ce mélange
et l’augmentation des températures au printemps,
provoquent la fonte des glaces
et les nutriments des algues sont relâchés.
Les phytoplanctons peuvent
accéder à ces nutriments
et grandissent avec la lumière,
ils deviennent de la nourriture
pour de plus grands planctons
qu’on appelle zooplanctons.
Et puis les baleines, les oiseaux et les poissons
mangent ces zooplanctons.
Donc, en fondant, la glace libère à court terme
des nutriments pour les animaux ici.
Mais il est important de rappeler
que sans les banquises,
tout le système sera en danger.
S’il n’y a pas de glace pendant l’hiver,
ou moins de glace,
ça veut dire qu’il y a moins d’algues,
or, c’est la base de la chaîne alimentaire ici.
C’est pour cela qu'il est important d’être ici,
pour comprendre ce qu'il se passe
- L’ONG veut faire pression
sur les gouvernements
parce que des négociations
ont eu lieu cette année à New York
et l'année prochaine, en 2020,
pour la signature d'un traité
sur la haute mer.
L’objectif est d’obtenir la création
d'un vaste réseau d'aires marines protégées
qui pourrait couvrir jusqu'à
30 % de la surface des eaux internationales.
Les enjeux de ce traité
sont très importants
et représentent un espoir énorme
pour la communauté scientifique
et les associations environnementales.
- Comment créer plus d'aires protégées
aidera à réduire le réchauffement climatique ?
- Le "cycle marin du carbone" dans l'océan
permet de capturer plus de CO2
et sans ce phénomène essentiel
fourni par les océans,
il y aurait 50 % de CO2
en plus dans l’atmosphère.
Les sanctuaires océaniques
sont des zones où l’activité industrielle est interdite,
comme la pêche,
l’exploitation minière sous-marine
ou l’extraction pétrolière.
C'est important pour pouvoir
maintenir la vie dans les océans
et les préserver pour le futur.
Les modèles climatiques qui sont
utilisés par les scientifiques
prédisent que la fonte de la banquise
va se poursuivre au cours
des prochaines décennies
et que celle-ci pourrait même
disparaître à l'été 2040.
- C’est quand même fou de se dire
que la puissance, quelque part,
qu’on a acquise
est démesurée au point
de pouvoir effacer,
d’ici quelques décennies,
ces paysages-là
où en fait, il n’y a pratiquement
aucun humain.
- C’est très triste de se dire
qu’un jour peut-être, ici,
ça sera du lichen et de la mousse